bundeskanzlerin angela merkel und
innenminister horst seehofer haben sich
darauf verständigt dass deutschland 1500
flüchtlinge von griechenland hier in
deutschland aufnehmen wird diese
nachricht spaltet jetzt dabei in
deutschland die geister der auf der
einen seite gibt es die befürworter die
sagen menschlichkeit ist momentan das
wichtigste gut dass wir in dieser zeit
haben aber auch die kritiker werden
immer lauter
diese waren davor voreilig menschen hier
in deutschland aufzunehmen
genau darüber streiten jetzt auch bild
vize paul ronzheimer und bild kolumnist
alexander von schönburg in unserem duell
[Musik]
ja nee du hast es angesprochen 1500
menschen soll deutschland aufnehmen ich
persönlich glaube das ist genau das
richtige zeichen zur richtigen zeit weil
wenn wir diese bilder sehen dort wenn
wir die kinder sehen ich war selbst als
reporter dort habe über sie immer wieder
berichtet glaube ich dass diese hilfe
dringend notwendig ist aber mir
gegenübersteht alexander von schönburg
der das genau anders sieht also ich habe
den nachteil dass ich nicht wie du schon
mal dort war ich glaube dann dein großer
vorteil ist du warst signale auf lesbos
du kennst die situation wirklich vor ort
und ich beobachte ich beobachte sie oder
beurteile sie aus dem bequemen sofa aus
berlin charlottenburg
das ist ein riesen nachteil für mich
aber auch du hast ein nachteil denn
deine deine sicht auf die dinge ist
sentimental getrübt und es ist ein ganz
großer gefahr
die mentalität in die politik hinein zu
bringen ich sage ein einfaches beispiel
wenn ich auf der strasse gehen und ich
sehe ein kind im schlamm liegen muss ich
selbstverständlich helfen das ist eine
frage der ethik selbstverständlich in
der politik ist die ethik eine andere du
musst in der politik immer auch denken
welche kollateral folgen kann so eine
entscheidung sein und wir befinden uns
in der gleichen situation eigentlich
spiegelbildlich die 2015
als ich am bahnhof in budapest getty die
massen versammelten und wir alle auch
bildmitte gefordert haben macht die
grenzen auf und wir finden in exakt der
gleichen situation mit dem unterschied
zu einem wir haben damals hatten wir die
solidarität von europa jetzt wird geht
deutschland alleine gegen ivana und wenn
du wenn wir jetzt alleine vorangehen
dann ist das zu recht ein signal auch
für die europäischen länder deutschland
nimmt auf wir können uns so aushalten
dass es werden das ist wie eine das ist
die wirksamste es werden millionen
nachkommen es ist die wirksam sein
werben nicht es werde licht millionen
nachkommen denn eines ist falsch was du
sagst ist es keinesfalls vergleichbar
mit 2015
die bedingungen sind ganz andere es gibt
momentan nicht den strom der menschen
die von der türkei nach griechenland
kommen relativ ruhig ist die situation
dort moment
es gibt nicht die den strom aus syrien
richtung türkei also wir sprechen erst
einmal von sehr viel weniger menschen
und es gibt auch für die menschen die
auf brechen nicht die möglichkeit so
einfach nach deutschland zu kommen wie
das 2015 war also ich glaube wir machen
ein fehler wenn wir 2015 mit heute
vergleichen das ist ein sehr sehr großer
unterschied und ich glaube dass
deutschland zu recht mit einem gutem
vorbild vorangehen will und insbesondere
eben den kindern vor ort helfen will ich
glaube dass das ein richtiges zeichen
ist und wenn jetzt sebastian kurz oder
anderen europa sagen das ist falsch und
sie wollen da nicht mitmachen dann ist
das eben so das finde ich aber kann
nicht bedeuten dass deutschland sich
dann raus halten soll
wenn man mit den flüchtlingen dort
spricht ich war nicht nur in moria
sondern auch in afghanistan libyen
syrien und in all diesen ländern wo
menschen aufbrechen und richtung
deutschland wollen ich kann nicht
bestätigen diese theorie des faktors
dass wenn wir jetzt ein bild produzieren
wir nehmen menschen auf dass das für den
menschen dort der entscheidende faktor
wäre zu sagen wir gehen jetzt auch los
nein die menschen zum einen aus gründen
des krieges aus den dramatischen
erlebnissen die sie haben wollen sie
dort weg so schnell wie möglich das
versuchen sie ohnehin
bei anderen gibt es diese
wirtschaftlichen gründe dort raus zu
gehen ich glaube dass es wichtig ist
zwei dinge zum einen die aufnahme und
zum anderen macht die kanzlerin und auch
marco und andere das genau richtig zu
sagen wir müssen jetzt aufpassen müssen
diese lager diese flüchtlingslager und
europäische kontrolle stellen denn ich
empfinde es als skandal dass in den
letzten fünf jahren griechenland nichts
getan hat um die bedingungen zu
verbessern nichts getan hat mit den
milliarden die dort rein kam aber das
kann ja jetzt nicht bedeuten okay
griechenland ist schuld wir lassen die
kinder jetzt alleine und wir sagen wir
versuchen jetzt nochmal nein ich finde
es braucht jetzt hilfe direkte hilfe für
die kinder
und es braucht dann eine struktur wo wir
bereits auf lesbos in den asylzentren
dann zumindest eine vorentscheidung
darüber treffen können wer hat überhaupt
eine chance auf asyl in europa und wenn
ich stimme dir 90 prozent der dingen bei
und ich kann selbstverständlich
nach vollkommen nachvollziehen was du
sagst nur in einem punkt widerspreche
ich und zwar ganz heftig deutschland
darf nicht vorangehen wenn deutschland
jetzt alleine voran geht ist das signal
an die ganze welt aber auch in
europäischen partner egal was ihr sagt
wir nehmen flüchtlinge auf das ist ein
signal
und dieses signal wird auch in afrika
gehört werden und selbstverständlich ist
die situation wir haben nicht wir haben
nicht die gleichen flüchtlingsströme wie
2015 aber dass wir es generell mit einer
grossen migrationsbewegungen moment zu
tun haben es sind millionen flüchtlinge
auch in der türkei ist in den nordafrika
sehr viel
selbstverständlich kann ist die große
gefahr dass gerade wenn deutschland
jetzt sagt kommt alle zu uns und
deutschland sei oder nicht kommt alle zu
uns manchmal ebenfalls springt man wird
davon sprechen dass wir eine bestimmte
anzahl man will gleichzeitig endkämpfe
errichten man setzt ja nicht das zeichen
wir nehmen jetzt alle man wird nicht
sagen die ganze sind die große die
ankommt die geste die ankommt ist
deutschland macht die türen auf und alle
anderen nicht und wenn du in nordafrika
etwas hören willst dann kommt der
deutschland stehen die türen offen und
da müsste ich mal dann rechne ich war in
libyen fünfmal als reporter und war dort
auch in diesen flüchtlingscamps diese
menschen die dort sind die brauchen kein
weiteres zeichen dass sie dort wegfallen
die wollen ohnehin schon alle weg das
macht keinen unterschied ob lena war
dann analysieren ein wird es macht
keinen unterschied sie werden dennoch
versuchen selbst wenn wir die schotten
dicht machen selbst wenn wir sagen diese
insel ist dicht niemand kommt breiter
habe hunderte und da kommt jetzt die
chance der politik mein hauptproblem ich
überhaupt kein problem 1500 leute
aufzunehmen überhaupt nicht wir haben
natürlich haben wir platz haben wir
platz für dafür in mecklenburg
vorpommern würden die gar nicht
auffallen
das ist überhaupt nicht mein problem
mein problem ist dass wir uns von diesen
bildern beeinflussen lassen deswegen
komme ich nochmal auf sentimentalität
oder das winterlicht
dann sind ja nicht nur bilder das emblem
das bei soll im schlamm sind die
hauptstraße liegen die nicht genügend zu
essen und nicht genügend wasser habe es
ist nach finde es falsch zu sagen die
politik solle sich nicht von bilder
beeindrucken lassen natürlich auch in
die politik immer emotionen eine politik
ist auch immer ein stück weit er war so
werde ich auch sagen und politiker
sollten menschen sein und politiker
sollten auch emotionen haben natürlich
müssen sie danach eine rationale
entscheidung treffen aber es sollte doch
kein politiker egal sein dass dort
kinder im
ein leben mit seinem ich komm ich konnte
viel wichtigeren viel wichtiger punkt
als diese 1500 was ist damit der mit der
grundsätzlichen problematik mein problem
an dieser geste politik an dieser ein
politik wir sind jetzt großzügig wir
müssen mal wir machen jetzt eine
einzelfalllösungen diesem ein
grundproblem ist damit dass wir durch
die dass wir ablenken
durch diese symbolpolitik von den
eigentlichen problemen wo ist jetzt die
stunde des entwicklungshelfers ministers
ich kenne einen gerd müller dass das
fußballer aber wir hatten jahrelang eine
entwicklungshilfeminister hieß es
angeblich auch gerd müller von denen
wenn nichts gehört die 1
es wäre jetzt die große stunde der
entwicklungshilfepolitik die letzten
jahre wäre die hilfe der werde der wert
die zeiten wird und müller hat übrigens
angekündigt dass er sich aus der politik
zurückzieht
aus meinem gesicht hat er sich hat er
sich schon seit jahren aus der politik
zurückgezogen
es wäre jetzt die stunde darüber
nachzudenken grundsätzlich wie sehen
diese bilder und jetzt vergeben wir
machen mit tacheles und rieben lösen die
probleme statt immer nur symbolisch hier
jemand einzelfall mäßig aufzunehmen was
ist mit den außengrenzen was es mit der
europäischen solidarität was ist mit der
entwicklungshilfe vor ort was ist mit
denen was ist mit dem schengen-abkommen
wie ist es überhaupt noch ist das
überhaupt noch tragbar sich vielleicht
muss doch für uns setzen der lösung
finden aber du kannst du dich mal
grundsätzlich keinen sprechen menschen
nein das kannst du dich nur politiker
solltest du solltest über grundsätzlich
keiten hätten wir schon viel länger
sprechen müssen in den vergangenen fünf
jahren
deutschland hätte für schärfer mit
griechenland umgehen müssen viel
schärfer intervenieren müssen und sagen
müssen das geht so nicht diese
flüchtlingslager akzeptieren wir so
nicht wir hätten viel direkter und
sicherlich auch schon viel mehr in
anderen ländern helfen müssen da gebe
ich dir sag mal riesige ländern sitzen
ja dabei gerade so ich sehe leider ist
wichtig zum einen den notleidenden in
der jetzigen situation helfen und
gleichzeitig etwas aufzustellen was die
kanzlerin möchte zu sagen wir gehen und
brauchen europäische flüchtlingslager um
dann eine entscheidung dort zu treffen
und natürlich müssen wir auch über
entwicklungspolitik sprechen aber das
ist aus meiner sicht eine totale
ablenkung jetzt zu sagen okay sein
möchte ihr harmonisch gewissen deswegen
möchte ich jetzt nicht über diese
menschen sprechen sie auch nicht überein
wir beruhigen unser persönliches
schlechtes gewissen als journalistin als
politiker als deutsche als wohlhabende
indem wir paar leute aufnehmen beruhigen
unser gewissen und durch dieses
beruhigen des gwm des gewissens wird
verhindert dass wir uns um die wirkliche
lösung der problematik gemacht wir haben
selbst das darf ich ja wir haben in
lenzen 15 wir haben den letzten fünf
jahren ja kaum leute aufgenommen und
auch in dieser zeit hast du haben sich
andere nicht mit dieser situation
auseinandergesetzt und gesagt wir müssen
grundsätzlich über entwicklungspolitik
sprechen denken so war der letzter
kommentar im bild über
entwicklungspolitik ist das große
problem dass es das thema
entwicklungshilfe irgendwie und sexy ist
und weißt du einmal du weißt du
kritisierst ja das ja in den letzten
fünf aber der konzern durch diese
gelungene rente ist ja der nette ist ja
sozusagen dann die zeit gegeben dass man
sich damit beschäftigt haben wir haben
jetzt zum beispiel einen tee dosieren
minister der sagt er tritt zurück
flecken sind da sehr offen einem
generationswechsel spricht vielleicht
können wir da wirklich wahr was
erreichen den westen eigentlich wichtige
ist dass wir den menschen vor ort helfen
in afrika aber wenige sind jetzt ja ein
lesbos und nicht mehr in afrika weißt du
warum müssen wir den menschen auch hält
weißt du wer mehr dafür tut dass keines
dass wir nicht von flüchtlingen
überrollt werden als die fliege ich
finde ich finde ich bin gewohnt marken
in die wortwahl des überrollen sehr sehr
schwierig denn ich glaube die
flüchtlinge suchen da auch in dieser
situation einfach eine bessere bleibe
und egal jetzt ob sie einen anspruch
haben man kann jeden menschen verstehen
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren